we're talking with millionaires this
hour to show you that can be done
millionaires next door and we happened
to have had as God would have it I was
gonna say coincidence in the lobby just
joining us hanging out dan is with us
who just stopped by to have a cookie
today and get a picture made and so
forth it's a commercial break and said
hey he would jump on hey Dan how are you
good sir how are you better than I
deserve where do you live south of
Washington DC Southern Maryland okay
cool so you want to join the
conversation because you've done this -
yeah I happen to be walking in heard the
topic it's like wow I knew answers of
some of the questions so how much is
your net how much is your nest egg my
wife and I were a little over 2 million
or right at that amount okay excellent
and how old are you 51 does if you want
okay so you've been working what 25
years about 27 about 27 years all right
cool and your income now household
income it's a little over 200 okay and
what was your average through that 27
years would you say I would say our
average household was 90,000 okay all
right she never you didn't average over
a hundred and what do you do for a
living what do y'all do for a living
both of you I'm a systems engineer and
my wife's a financial analyst okay very
cool very cool and so did you what what
is the money and is that your 401ks and
my mutual funds are what what's it in
it's a 1.2 mil in all retirement pretty
much mostly mutual funds a little bit of
stocks I would say it's conservative as
well relatively conservative not full
bore stocks the rest is real estate we
have a home rental property and also we
bought a condominium at that beach about
five years ago and started listening
about five years ago and a lot of that
was a leveraged or debt and just
recently paid off a couple of weeks ago
I would have tried to do the debt-free
scream piece but my wife said you're not
doing that without me unfortunately she
couldn't be here today
okay well we'll schedule that later for
you we'll get you back on that's fine so
you're debt-free of course I haven't
asked the other people that and another
should have done that but they all are
okay James City that we did check with
them all right
and so this is 401k money in return
rental real estate basically and your
home and so you have a good match at
your companies over the years not
spectacularly three to five percent in
there okay did you have any one big hit
or did you inherit money or did you
start with wealth no didn't start with
wealth but uh you know I grew up in
Maryland went to University of Maryland
my parents did pay I lived at home my
parents did pay for tuition then which
when I started in 1982 it was like about
seven hundred dollars a semester mm-hmm
and so I did have to had no college debt
or anything like that
uh-huh so I took advantage of being in
state I guess I've always thought
financially and the compound interesting
the interest piece on my I and what kind
of things it does inspire you the first
time you understand I put Ben and Arthur
in my first book and I've tried to use
that chart
ever since when we're teaching about
this because it just shows you the power
of of saving money and when you start
talking about saving a hundred bucks a
month you know that that turns into a
million dollars you know and you know
for those for that number of years and
really that's right where you are you're
a little obviously double that but but
so you don't attribute this to any one
big thing I mean you didn't like strike
it rich at the poker table or have one
stock that went through the roof or
something like that no there was no
get-rich-quick and that she didn't hit
the lottery not at all it was all live
below I mean some of my family I'm sure
thinks I've been cheap through the years
but uh the only new car I bought was
right out of college they're not kind of
signed off it's like that's the thing
you do but we bought one other new one
but that was with cash everything else
has been with cash never had a car loan
or anything it's kind of nice to go in
there not have to worry about that so no
student loans no car loans the whole
time no okay so staying out of debt
enabled you to do this you guys take
vacations modest modifications we're
looking to take more now oh you got a
beach house so yeah yeah we go there a
few times a year for sure very cool so
you're listening I'll say the same thing
to you I said to the other guys there's
a 24 year old version of you out there
right now what do you tell them how did
you become worth $2,000,000 don't try to
keep up with the Joneses live below your
means always before looking apply
yourself at whatever your career goal is
and uh as I've gotten older and I wish I
had known younger you know really work
with your spouse and be a team mm that
helps a great deal
very cool dan thanks for jumping on the
mic good stuff very good stuff very cool
you